on and you are live
chairman thank you good evening
and welcome to the central area planning
committee
meeting on wednesday the 24th of
february 2021
my name is councillor michael edwards
and i am the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
covid 19 pandemic
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present
in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains
muted when not addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any
unintentional disturbances this meeting
will be hosted remotely via conferencing
software
this allows members of the public to
virtually attend the meeting
whilst being able to protect themselves
and others
and observe the government's lockdown
measures
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded members and officers
during each item please use the hands up
function of the meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
points of order
or indicating that you must leave the
meeting the chat function should not be
used for questions or
any other purposes when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers
please ensure you'll reference you
reference a page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
now if i ask officers taking part in the
meeting to introduce themselves starting
with mr lee
good evening members i am matthew lee
lead specialist place at morton district
council
and chief planning officer thank you
and hannah dungate
good evening chairman and members i'm
hannah dungate
planning specialist within the
development management team
thank you thank you and katie fuller
good evening members my name is katie
fuller i'm clark to this evening's
committee
thank you are there any other officers
present
okay thank you before i call on the
clerk to take the roll call of committee
members can i ask those cancers in
attendance
to introduce themselves please are there
any
no okay thank you katie please can you
now carry out a roll call of members to
confirm who is in attendance thank you
yes chairman members i will call your
names in alphabetical order
and counselor miss bill please
president thank you
councillor edwards president thank you
councillor heard
you're muted to councillorhood
sorry chairman good evening katie
chairman and colleagues present
thank you councillor lagan
good evening everyone i'm president
casey thank you thank you
councillor mays good evening
present thank you councillor morris
good evening and welcome thank you
councillor none hi casey yes i'm here
good evening everyone
thank you councillor seancey
here katie thank you thank you
councillor stilts
yes good evening everybody i'm present
katie
thank you councillor swain yes
present good evening
that's all of the that's the whole roll
call chairman
thank you thank you um i want to
too may i have the apologies for absence
please okay
there are none chairman thank you
and agenda item three
minutes of the second of december it is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 2nd of december 2020
found on pages 7 to 14 are approved as a
true and accurate record
i so move and if you wish to second that
motion
please unlock your microphone and state
your name now please
seconded counselor numb thank you cancer
none if any members wishes to raise any
matter
of accuracy please use the hands up
function to indicate and i will invite
you to speak
katie please can you revise if any
member has indicated a wish to speak
no member has indicated chairman
i'm sorry just going back a bit did i
mention that the minutes are on page 17
to 14.
i think i did didn't i yes okay katy
will now take the vote please each
member in alphabetical order
um please state four against abstain
excuse me check can we do this
of interest to disclose the existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniar interests relating to items
of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interests
as soon as they become aware that they
should should the need arise throughout
the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate
and i will invite you to speak
katie can i advise you if any member has
indicated which to speak
no member has indicated chairman okay
item five sorry sorry chairman
i did put my hand up uh i believe i have
got my hand
council morris um i'd just like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest
um i frequented the waffle bar uh my
daughter
absolutely loves it and um when she
heard that um
we was uh sitting on this one today she
actually informed me that
if i didn't vote for um whatever
proposal they put forward
that she would uh leave home and never
speak to me again
so i'd like to just uh announce that um
i will most
definitely be against anything they put
up now i'm only joking that's just a bit
of satire
um yeah i've used the waffle bar quite a
bit with my door
thank you thank you cancer morris
item five application 20 stroke
zero one two zero eight stroke
lbc this is building consent the waffle
bar
144 high street modern cm 95bx
we moved to a gender item planning
application which i've just mentioned
and these found on pages 15
to 90. in a moment i will call on the
officer to present this item
remember as a reminder that if you wish
to speak on this item
please make this known by using the
hands up function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn
and if you please keep your points clear
and succinct
uh katie please can you present your
report
sorry hannah this can you repent of
people
yes thank you chairman listed building
consent
is sought for the removal of
the brick pier from the east boundary
wall of number 144
the high street malden number 144 is a
grade 2 listed building dating from the
medieval period
the existing brick wall however appears
to have been constructed in the 1930s
when the adjacent property
number 146 was built which is located
here
although the structure in itself is not
listed it is protected as a structure
within the cartilage of number 144
as it predates 1948. as such the removal
of the brick pier requires listed
building consent
here is the location plan for the
proposal showing the application site
and here is the block plan for the
proposal
this plan shows the positioning of the
brick pier to be removed
here which is set back from the back
edge of the footpath by approximately
4.9 meters
3.9 meters sorry there is also a brick
here which is adjacent to the footpath
which will be retained as shown here
the plan also shows the location of
three brick piers which have already
been removed from
the rear of the site which are here
[Music]
this is a photo of the front of number
146
take a 144 sorry taken from the high
street
it shows the brick pier to be retained
at the front of the site here
as well as the brick pier to be removed
which is further back behind it
this is another photo from the high
street taken in front of number 146
and as you can see from this photo the
brick pier to be removed is not visible
this is the photo of the brick pier to
be removed taken from within the site
and this is another photo taken further
back within the site
and this is a photo of an existing
location of
a brick pier which has already been
removed within the site
um to conclude as this is a listed
building consent application
the proposed development can only be
assessed in relation to its impact
on the significance of the listed
building which in this case is number
144
the council's heritage and conservation
specialist has raised
no objections to the proposal and has
commented that the brick wall is of
limited historical significance
in relation to the setting of the listed
building and modern conservation area
as such the removal of the brick pier
would result in no harm to the
significance of the listed building
and it is therefore recommended that
list of building consent is granted for
the proposal
subject to a condition relating to the
making good of the brick wall
with matching bricks should any damage
occur to the face of the wall
thank you chairman that is all thank you
hannah uh we have one public producer
participant for this planning
application and in line with the public
participation scheme
and knowing that inviting objective mr
david smythe
on behalf of the modern society to read
how to submission
may remind you that you're allocated two
minutes only for public speaking
in accordance with the scheme so when
you're already mrs moon
thank you
good evening yes david smythe
representing the mortgage society
the mortgage society objects to this
proposal
the applicant themselves admit that the
wall in question
is in a precarious state and may well
need addressing
and is made up of a mishmash of historic
bricks and modern threatens
several of the piers further along the
wall have previously been removed
and consequently the structures
integrity of the wall
has already been compromised any further
reduction
or removal of peers will only hasten the
instability of the whole wall
and should be resisted lack of
maintenance should not be seen
not should not be a reason to destroy
specific architectural elements
the circular form of the peers is an
example of an unusual solution
to the need to provide peers to ensure
structural stability
their unique art deco style of stack
bonding
is not inherently a strong method of
brick bonding and therefore needs to be
treated with respect
remaining peers are in our view a very
attractive example
of an architectural style that although
not related to
the adjacent list of buildings is
underrepresented within the conservation
area
as to the eclectic mix and is just as
justifiably worthy
of retention and safeguarding the area
where the lorry has been shown this area
is often used for car parking or access
to the buildings at the rear
and even at its narrowest point is
adequate for such purposes
the width of the access at this point is
shown to be 2.8 meters
and as the available width further back
at the corner of the listed building
is narrower at approximately 2.6 meters
then removing the pier
would not create a wider access and will
be of no benefit
we consider this important vestige of
20th century
architectural style not widely
represented within the conservation area
is worthy of retention and consent
should be withheld
thank you councillors thank you mr smite
um are there any offers wish to comment
on that before we move on
to the recommendation no this time thank
you chairman
okay uh the recommendation that set out
within the report is as follows the
recommendation
that planning application 20 stroke zero
one two zero eight stroke
lbc for the waffle bar 144 high street
modern
be approved subject to the conditions as
detailed in section 8 of this report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please don't meet your microphone
and state your name now
counselor spilts
thank you i will now invite members to
make any comments on the report
katie who has indicated their wish to
speak please
i think we ought to go if i may to
cancel amaze as this was a calling
on her request thank you
thank you mr chairman um i i shall i
shall be brief
um although this may be a wall in
somewhat of poor condition
i think that is somewhat deliberate on
the part of
the um applicant however
it does allow sufficient room for
vehicles to get through
it will have significant it will cause
significant harm to the high street
scene
as i see it every time i walk down the
high street
and pass the waffle bar um i think it is
as
mr smize said of historical interest
very unusual
and it does provide some stability to
that wall
as can be seen from those that have
already been removed
there may be issues further along the
wall
um however its historical value um
is is quite important and i'd actually
like to hand to
uh councillor nun who is much better
informed on these things
and our architectural heritage um and so
i'd like to pass to my um
my colleague uh councillor nunn thank
you
i mean are you happy for me yes
councilman
thank you very much well i mean i've
known this wall um
all my life and uh i've always been
interested in it and it's to a lot of
people it's just a wall but
i'm not convinced it's 30s i think
actually parts of it are earlier than
the 30s
and as far as i can see it's a unique
piece of architectural
or built heritage um in the conservation
area
walls were built like this sometimes to
avoid believing or not corners being
knocked off
and you can see examples of that in
other buildings so
at bailey road for example the building
on the corner of bailey road and gate
street has got a rounded corner
so i think that's all part of it it was
also um
used during the second world war by the
the home guard
so it has got quite a story behind it
i'm very surprised
to be honest with you that the
conservation officer
has said what he said but as mr lee has
said to us in the past
the conservation officer is only a
consultant
but i am surprised because i think it is
an integral part of the story
of 144 high street
um i got very confused by the
application at first because i thought
it was to take the wall down
i didn't realize until i looked at the
excellent
um presentation by hannah that it was a
one buttress rather than the front and
the you know the
rounded part in the front but what
troubles me
uh is something that mr smyre said
that buttresses are there for a purpose
they're there for stability
and one wonders why the why and how the
previous buttresses have been removed
actually
um but is it a case and i i know i know
it's specialist on on buildings
is it a case that if buttresses are
removed the wall
is in danger so i think for all of those
reasons
i'm very concerned by this but primarily
i'm concerned because i think it is an
important
historical feature and part of the story
of 144 and part of the story of the town
thank you very much thank you cancer
none
one any of the officers want to uh the
officer come back on
on any other uh observations from
counselling none
thank you chairman um happy to uh come
back
um as ms
explain this application is a list of
building applications
so it is materially different to a
planning application per se
um the only considerations that we can
have
as the decision makers is whether or not
this
wall and in this case specifically the
uh
pillar um
add to the historic nature of the listed
building uh whether or not they
are a key component to preserving and
enhancing the character
and historic uh significance of this
structure
um as
councilman said you know the historic
advisor is
just that an advisor to consultee and
that
goes for any console t um
their response whether it's highways
whether it's historic environment with
its environment agencies etc
is a material consideration but it isn't
a simple case just because someone
advises something we
have to do it as decision maker we have
to just make sure we have taken that on
board and um
as i said you know we've been advised
it's the 1930s
ball council none says you may think
it's slightly older than that and
quite possibly it is but i think as
officers and as the lpa we consider that
the actual wall does not add
significantly to the
setting of the list of building to the
value of the listed building
and as this is a legacy building
application per se that's the thing we
should be looking at
although it may be an attractive feature
within the street scene although it may
be an unusual architectural feature
within the street scene
that doesn't automatically mean that
it's something that can be refused
it would be different if they were
looking to remove the whole wall partly
because it's in a conservation end it
would actually need planning permission
on its own right
in that instance but this is just one
piece so it
um i can't remember the piece of case
law off the cuff um but that means it
doesn't need planning permission to do
his case still that's clear about that
um but it does need listed building
center but it is only about the impact
on this to building so
i think members need to be conscious
about that when having the debate
it isn't just a case of this walls a
nice architectural feature
in the street scene it is about its
impact on the listed building per se
thank you chairman thank you mr lee um
i think cancer logan next
yeah thank you chair i think scout house
actually sort of
highlighted quite a few of the the
issues that i have with application it's
very easy
um to wash away history
uh for convenience and i think this is
absolutely a unique fitting in
in the town and does um add to
144 and 148 and i think when you look at
policy d3 with the conservation heritage
assets it's clear because it talks about
development proposals that affect the
heritage asset
and it's setting required to preserve or
enhance its special character appearance
setting including the street scene
landscape value
um well this certainly does i think it's
a very very
valuable asset to have we've been
clearing that policy
i think um i was quite surprised and
shocked when i looked at the
the back of it to find that the previous
pillars had been removed and i wonder
how they were removed we need to look
into that
but so that's not not for consideration
tonight so i
i echo my colleagues um comments
i think that the bachelor should be
saved it doesn't cause any problem it is
uniqueness and
i believe colleagues that it does
actually add to the
the value of one four four one four
eight
so thank you chair thank you council
um councillor
and thank you chairman i'm i'm happy to
speak but i think the others were before
me
please i can't um oh council remains
again
that legacy hand i think it was
councillor sean want to see then swain
and myself
although okay cancer chauncey sorry i
can't see
and you're muted
still muted yes thank you chairman yes
um
thank you well um obviously i'll just be
brief because
i um had almost identical notes
before me as counselor none i agree
with the things um that the member of
the public was talking about that the
member from the malden society i and
and i am greatly concerned about the
stability of the wall
because as someone who said before me
these pillars are not
there you know just for decoration they
are indeed decorative
um but they must have had something to
do
um with um you know the stability of the
wall originally um
you know i think that almost goes
without saying and i do worry
that if this pier is taken down whether
the whole wall will come down
i mean care has not been taken with that
wall
as is immediately obvious um i walked
past there the other day
someone has been careless with the top
of that wall
as i think has been mentioned by
somebody else it's obviously
obvious that a truck can reverse down
there past the front pillar
and that pillar so i really cannot see
why this pillar must come down i think
the whole wall
should be reinforced properly including
that
pillar that that is that is my opinion
thank you chairman
thank you council shawnee country swain
um thank you chairman um i know what
matt lee has said about um
it's being really distinct from waffle
bar itself
um i am i'm concerned an interesting
feature of the wall which
maybe council none might be able to say
something about is the
the top of the um the pillar
particularly on the
at the pavement and the whether the
indentation in it had some purpose for
either
another structure or ornament of some
sort
however having said that um
the the key thing is the the other
pillars have been removed
um and this the one in question has been
damaged and i'm not
um uh i'm not should we say favorable
just
disposed to people who damage things and
then complain that it
it's unstable and that applies to the
wall itself
but the pier and if the pier is removed
i think reinforcement in the form of
another alternative pier would still be
required
um but the the point about impact is
that um the peers further back
are relatively um minor
in their uh what you say their
attractiveness or their importance
compared with the one at the front on
the front of the wall
that is what needs to be retained
and the wall needs to be properly
restored
uh which may well involve reinfor um a
replacement pillar of some sort
so i um while i would like to see the
existing one
that's in question uh restored
um i don't think there's sufficient
argument
um uh in favor of of um
retaining it as long as the
wall is stabilized and
renovated and the pillow the pavement
side is correct
so um i
will accept the officer's recommendation
but i um i think it needs a reinforced
condition
uh concerning the state of the wall
otherwise i can quite see the um
the property only coming back before
long and saying the wall's just
um is completely unstable i think the
wall needs
um proper repair and restoration
um uh and if that involves an
alternative pier
so be it but otherwise i would go along
with the
the recommendation concerning this video
up here
thank you thank you councillor swain
right
um councillor hood
thank you chairman i'll be brief as well
because most of what i want to say has
been said
um although the matter before us today
is looking at this single buttress
uh the cumulative effect of the other
buttresses being removed as well
really does um concern me i am very
surprised also that the conservation
officer
has decided that this has no
architectural
merit but my my main concern is
you know a buttress is it's an
architectural structure built against or
projecting from a wall which serves to
support
or reinforce the wall why on earth would
you want to remove it
if it's there for safety reasons
because the ones that have already been
removed and there is a question over why
they've been removed
why would you remove yet another one to
make it even more unsafe
so i really echo what my colleagues have
already said thank you chairman thank
you council
heard um sorry who's next cat shortness
is that a
legacy and
i apologize if it is um no
i haven't got a hand up okay thank you
can't you like your hands up
you want to come back again you're muted
you're muted yes regarding the other
pillars um did they get adjusted
building consent to be removed
yeah um they they didn't um as far as i
can see
from the planning history of the site
thanks thank you are there any more
questions
okay so that's it sorry
well i was going to recommend we go to
the vote gym i was just going to say
that
has got his hand up chairman oh sorry i
didn't see that
yeah i can't say that sorry i was going
to say the same thing actually
thank you so was it
okay can we now move to the vote please
katie can you please um now take the
vote
yes chairman members i will take your
names please could you indicate whether
you are
for against or um abstaining
from the officer's recommendation for
approval
thank you councillor miss bill
against thank you councillor edwards
well listening to the debate um i was
thinking about before but listening to
the debate i think now
i'm convinced that i'll be also against
thank you
councillor heard against
thank you councillor lagan against
please kt
thank you councillor mays against katie
thanks
thank you councillor morris
um after uh reading the officer's report
i
uh my predisposition was to be to
go with the officer's report but after
listening to the excellent
debate and especially uh mr smythe i'm
now going to abstain
thank you councillor none
against please coach thank you
councillor
shawnee against thank you
else against katie
thank you councillor swain um
four in the expectation that the
strength that condition three will be
strengthened
thank you chairman that is one four
eight against and one abstention
thank you katie uh as the recommendation
was for
removal but we now have to come decide
on the reasons for
going against the camp uh officer's
recommendation
yes please please
mr lee's advice please chair
i would like to propose that the um
the buttress is retained because it's an
integral part
of the design of a historically
significant
feature uh within the cartilage of 144
high street i will second that motion
council amaze
mr lee is that um sufficient
to chairman i think that's quite a clear
reason for refusal so
it's obviously within the members
committee's gift to determine the
application yeah but i think that's fine
okay thank you so do we need to um go
any further with that well
that is carried then that it's uh
refused
that need to be voted
i think a number of members have voiced
concerns about the safety of the wall
and i wonder whether whether councillor
none might consider that to be
incorporated in the reason if i may
chair um i was trying to focus very much
on the uh listed building
element the list of building consent
which is why i
i didn't sort of say anything else i
just spoke about the
integral part of the historical feature
i do agree with councillord i do think
it will make it
unstable but i don't think that's a
valid reason
uh thank you okay thank you
okay can i just echo what councilman has
said i'd advise that he's taking the
correct approach
thank you mr lee katie can we now have a
vote on
the reasons for the um
refusal of the uh application
yes chairman so members um we are voting
for the reasons for refusal
as proposed by councillor none
if you could indicate whether you're for
against or abstaining please
starting with councillor miss bill
[Music]
thank you councillor edwards
this is for the approve uh the reasons
to refuse to to refuse the yeah
sorry before i got a bit confused
four please katie thank you councillor
mays
four please katie councillor morris
abstain thank you councillor none
four please casey thank you councillor
shauna c four
katie thanks for stilts
okay okay thank you councillor swain
german that is eight for no
none against and two abstentions thank
you
katie agenda item six
any other items of business that the
chairman of the committee decides are
urgent i have none
therefore go to item seven closure of
the meeting members thank you for your
contributions this evening
and i draw the meeting to close at six
thirty six
um pm and as the meeting is now closed
members are requires not to enter into
any further discussion on this forum and
to please leave the meeting promptly
thank you very much for attending thank
you